الان حول الخبر العاجل الذي اورته قبل
الفاصل مراسل العربيه اذا يؤكد الان اصابه
سته اسرائيليين ثلاثه منهم بحال خطره بعد
اطلاق النار في مستوطنه نفيه يعقوب في
القدس اذا هذه صور اوليه اذا همم
هذا الهجوم اذا قبل قليل طبعا همم نستمع
الى الصوت الطبيعي اذا سته اسرائيليين
اصيبوا منهم ثلاثه في حال خطر
[موسيقى]
اذا همم واضح صوت اطلاق الرصاص المكان اذا
مستوطنه الذي يعقوب او مستوطن النبي يعقوب
اذا في القدس همم وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
تتحدث عن مقتل مطلق الرصاص اذا لانه وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه تتحدث عن مقتل الرصاص في
المستوطنه النبي يعقوب اذا في القدس هذه
المشاهد الاوليه اذا المكان او على مقربه
من المكان اللي وقع اطلاق النار حتى الان
ال- همم المعطيات تشير الى اصابه سته
اسرائيليين ثلاثه منهم في حال ان همم خطره
طبعا يبدو ان هذا الهجوم ردا على التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في جنين همم الخارجيه
الامريكيه كانت اعرضت عن عدم رضاها من
قرار السلطه الفلسطينيه بوقف التنسيق
الامن مع الجانب الاسرائيلي على خلفيه
الهجوم على مدينه جنين بحياته تسعه
فلسطينيين
وطالبت الخارجيه الامريكيه بالعوده عن هذا
القرار والذي اتخذ بعد اجتماع طارئ
للقياده